yes so the next talk will be
by uh trey fong kyogre from uc irvine
so he will talk about constructing braid
with unbalanced marginals
thank you very much will
uh i would like to thank uh simone and
katie for a wonderful workshop and
giving me the opportunity to be here
and i'm looking forward to
meeting all of you and having the chance
to chat during the week it's it's an
absolutely wonderful place and
an excellent uh
environment for all of us
so uh i'm uh i'll be talking today about
the title you can read there the most
likely evolution of diffusing invention
particles in the spirit of every
schrodinger it's about
uh uh coupling our distributions with an
equal amount uh marginalized joint work
with yongshin chen who is uh
the heart of the team uh he's here and
michele pavone
so
i plan to give you a little bit of
context and motivation for interpolating
distributions with unequal marginals
then i'll move on to uh optimal mass
transport very briefly and
and it's uh sibling the schrodinger
bridge problem
uh or uh regularized uh optimal
transport and we heard a very
interesting very nice talk uh by augusto
just now
so it's it's nice segue here
and then i'll uh tell you about uh some
uh
the exactly the new insights of this
work
uh on coupling distributions and
balanced margins
in the spirit of schrodinger going back
sort of like to the horse's mouth some
of the spirit of the original
um motivation
so
uh the coupling between distributions
and the word the buzzword is morphing
conjurors
for those of you i have seen terminator
two conjures up images of this um
uh this playful reference to this um
liquid metal that
it's a futuristic contraption that uh
transforms to any shape but of course
the density is not mass is not preserved
along this
and and even though we don't make any
claim of competing with the uh
with the film industry
uh similar problems arise they
have a reason very often in many
application areas and this over here is
a little bit of a reference
to some applications that uh motivated
uh
our group to look into optimal mass
transport back in the
um around 2005 6 and so on
again coupling distributions that have
an equal mass so the the picture over
here that you see
uh represents a tracking with some some
radar so here you have a signal and the
blue or segments here you have a
spectrogram so this is sort of the
information that you can pull out of
that
and this here is some geodesic in in in
optimal transport sense linking
all of these sample points
which
pictorially can be shown here in a
non-parametric way to capture exactly
the the
doppler shift of a of a moving object
uh this is a morphing of speech i will
skip uh further details of that this is
this goes quite far back and this is
some sort of a smoothing of a
a spectrogram of a temperature uh field
for non-invasive
sensing so the bottom line is um
no matter how you look at it in some
applications for example in spectral
analysis
the power spectrum of the time series at
one point in time and another
does not have enough the same power
so you you in order to link those with
let's say um
optimal transport geodesic
of course you can normalize but that's
not quite natural because you're
interested in capturing how the energy
shifts across frequencies and the same
applies with images
so
that naturally led us back then to study
the work that was already uh uh
exploding in optimal transport and and
this is a completely incomplete
you know reference to all in this
workshop you're very well aware of
optimal transport and the history
so back then uh prior to
2010
we played with the idea of mixing
different
[Music]
different metrics for example in
interpolating distributions
uh let's say this is a density one and
this is a density two that don't have
equal masses so the masses these are
measure
so the the notation is a little bit uh
the f represents here density oh no
actually it doesn't represe sorry this
notation here is kind of inconsistent
with the
the so there are two measures here or
densities and you try to mix
some vacherstein distance between the
two with
with um
different other
uh metrics that uh
regularize so for example here the one
idea that was tried back then is to mix
an l1 distance at the start and another
one at the end representing errors and
then vases times in between so that you
get the benefits of weak star continuity
the interesting thing and i'm going to
refer in more
discuss this anymore is that there were
interesting dual
formulations of such problems that
allowed us to interpolate but again
all of this was
a little bit ad hoc and
we come to the
2000 and and beyond which uh sort of uh
the
the idea of regularizing ben abu
brainier
formulation of matching marginals
uh was blossoming and there are very
many
different ideas of
setting up
convex optimization problems
to link marginals for example
you have two marginals row zero
and uh row one
and you might want to
satisfy the continuity equation
and penalize this is very much in the
spirit of the previous
picture
uh
penalized distance you know at one
endpoint or both end points
to turn marginal
or here you have a source term
and you penalize the source term
in the
regularizing uh function there
another option we have had quite a bit
of
usage in applications is
you have
a uh
an expression of this type with again
it's convex in both s and r
uh and
we come to the mid
2000s with uh
liero
it's a beautiful paper and many others
that fall at the same time
that basically explore the mixing of two
metrics
so
um
now
today's lecture is we'll focus mostly on
the schrodinger bridge problem
which is a sibling of optimal transport
the regularized transport problem where
you have um and i'll talk a little bit
about the history of the problem and the
rationale before i go into the new ideas
that come through this
so this problem is a problem with large
deviations and i'll talk more about this
that leads
to an optimization problem of this sort
so you have in the right hand side of
the continuity equation you have a
laplacian and you can put an epsilon
there or not
and uh i thought of as a regularization
of optimal transport and allows you to
use the shrink or algorithm for the
solution
and um
[Music]
there's much of the theory some of this
i'll allude to or discuss
there is
an interesting time symmetric
formulation of it where
you remove the laplacian from here
at the cost of adding this uh
fischer
uh
term in the in the coast
and there's a lot of work on this which
again i'm not going to give
a complete
literature
survey here
so
uh let me give you a little bit of inter
sort of
going back the history of the the
schrodinger problem so through the year
1931-32
he wanted to get a physical
understanding and a
classical understanding of his own
equation
so he postulated a certain gedanken
experiment with classical particles
stochastic particles so he posed the
following question he said suppose that
you have a a collection of particles
that abide by a certain probability
distribution this is
their initial distribution
let's say for example i have a box over
here with molecules of oxygen and i just
open it up and they spread all over the
room they are gaussian particles they
have to spread all over the place
however i measure five minutes later and
i find them here
you can't tell me they're not there
because that's where they are
it's not consistent with the brownian
diffusion
so something strange happened and they
all reassemble there so he asked the
question how did it go from here to
there
so it was an interesting sort of
experiment
the
the mathematics of this took 50 years to
be i really understood properly and the
problem to be posed properly
but schrodinger
uh with the limited tools at the time
not only he posed the problem he solved
the problem
his mathematical proof was this is the
answer because it makes sense
physically and it was correct uh of
course it it took the rest of us or you
know the 50 years to to understand even
the the the problem so here is exactly
the reformulation of the problem i
explained
the statement of the problem
that schrodinger came up with
cloud of brownian particles
uh empirical distributions are two
points in time
and the empirical distribution is not
compatible with the transition mechanism
so
of the many possible ways which could
have happened which one is the most
likely
so that's a problem in large deviations
um this um was
seen as such by filmer 1988 and it
really amounts to the following thing
you have a prior reference measure
which is the winner measure on the path
space of the particles
so you have the collection of all
possible paths and r is the winner
measure
so then you're asking
uh out of
all the the um
the uh
the probability measures distributions
on paths with the given marginals
which one is the most likely which is
the one
that uh minimizes the relative entropy
to the prior
over
ps in this set
and uh
this is this uh relates to sonoff's
theorem and that's the proper
formulation so now the connection to
optimal mass transport is simply that if
you have a diffusion
uh with a drift here by the asano's
theorem the relative entropy is
essentially a quadratic expression
so
um
so then the schrodinger bridge problem
can be translated into the problem we
just saw
in the previous slide
and now the solution of this problem
which again schrodinger came up with
he dissected everything in space and
time
counted the beams how many go from here
to there and somehow
he came up with the answer
he couldn't justify it and there was
great mathematicians
that kept adding to this until 50 years
later where there was a very clear
picture of the problem
so the minimizer and this is the the
flow of one one time densities
has to be factored into a product five
five star so this basically relates to
the
game sort of the idea of this quantum
mechanical description of probability
being the square of the wave function so
it's kind of analogous but it's not the
same of course
and these two objects here two functions
have to satisfy a bunch of equations
here and this is the schrodinger problem
the shortcut system that we saw a little
bit earlier in augustus
uh presentation all be it in a slightly
different form
so the phi's have to multiply th these
two functions find phi hat
uh have to multiply to row zero and row
one at the two ends these are coupled by
the boundary conditions
and they have to relate through the
prior evolution
in this way
so
um
going forward in time phi hat
has to uh produce
fi had a time t and all the way to the
end and
solving in the backward direction
this is the backward backwards the heat
equation
uh phi
is uh
is will produce
phi zero
so iterating this scheme
is basically a synchronition
so or schematically this is the initial
density given
and the prior law will tell you that it
spreads out but you make a measurement
it's inconsistent and you would like to
match them so this is the short gear
bridge
this is a one-time margin of slices
and
the solution that i just outlined is
somehow by hook or by crook or by the
sinkhole algorithm you have to break
the two distributions into a product
the fives and the five hats
and the five hats propagate according to
heat equation forward the files
the heat equation backwards in time
and they have to satisfy this this uh
two point boundary
uh
value
constraints
and then uh the schrodinger bridge is
the product of two distributions this
one and that one and it gives you the
the matching now
the
uh outline of sb
uh strolling a bridge problem
theory of course this goes uh further
uh to the situation where you have a
diffusion with a drift term
and even uh
a coefficient in front of the uh
the the brownian uh
excitation
again i'm kind of repeating the same
things though i'm adding a little bit of
notation
so r
is the prior of
of the law
there
uh for every probability uh law on path
spaces
our t represents the marginal at t
and our steep represents the the joint
marginal tns
uh
this notation rxy
is the law conditioned on
the
the process taking these particular
values at the two endpoints this is
what's called the bridge the pinned
bridge so if you pin it at two points
the law and the paths the the mass that
sits on a particular
let's say
continuous functions that go from x to y
is is provided by this law
in general if you have a probability
long path spaces you can disintegrate
the measure and you have the pin
weighed in by the joint uh marginal at
the two end points
and you can do this for the prior you
can do it for the solution the p that
you're looking
so the solution of the schrodinger
bridge problem which is
find the minimizing of the
relative entropy between p that is
consistent and the r that is not
has a can be
seen very nicely when you start
disintegrating the measure
and then you can see that the relative
entropy is the sum
of these two terms
so this is this takes the relative
entropy of the
the pin bridges
and this is between the two end points
and
the terms are positive and this one can
become zero when the pin bridges are
identical so the only thing you need is
to find out
the uh
the adjustment so that the marginals are
correct
between the joint uh
distributions the two end points
this is a static and this is the dynamic
problems and this is their relationship
so
the relationship
is that the solution
is the pin bridges
[Music]
this term stays and then you have to
find the optimal of the static problem
so under
natural uh
mild conditions there exists
functions f and g
this can be seen as lagrange multipliers
of the problem of
adjusting the two ends
and they are solutions of the shortcut
system
and then
the joined marginal
is basically
uh
a diagonal scaling
of the prior
so you multiply by two functions
and then the same thing is for the law
of
so so here you have the law on path
and
you have simply to scale it
by two two functions
at the beginning and
so um
a little bit more about the schrodinger
system
there is a relationship between this f
and the g
to the original
expressions for fire heart and phi
in in schrodinger's formulation
the for this more general problem
the the
the schrodinger system for the the two
factors of the one time densities obey
the
the four words
uh focus planck equation and this is the
adjoint
and very much like in the case of
brownian diffusion
the the two point uh
coupled nonlinear at the two ends of the
interval
then
again
the one time densities which are simply
the
the uh the rho at the time t is the
product of the fine phi hat
the the t time marginals and these are
the law
of a diffusion which is very much like
the prior
the prior sits up there
and the diffusion is simply the same
except that you have an added term here
that is responsible for matching the two
end modules
so
okay so now
where
do we come in in this talk
so the uh we are interested in
revisiting the problem with losses
unbalanced marginals
and of course you can add a
a source term
uh but again how do you physically
justify this it depends on the context
so here we're trying to follow the
rationale of schrodinger just revisiting
exactly the original
setting
so again
we postulated we have particles
that are
given at two points in time
and you can think of them as tracer
particles like for example let's say you
have fluid flow
and you'd like to know what happens to
the currents
sometimes or sediment transport and
experiments like that take place all the
time so you drop particles in which
somehow you can measure later on
and try to find out what happened
and some of those particles they sit to
the bottom and they're gone they're
finished
uh the same thing happens when you for
example you have neutrons that go
through
some sort of a substance and you you
expect some effect and some of them
fizzle so probably that's not a good
example but the tracer example is
probably the best one so you start with
an empirical distribution and some of
and then you have a marginal at some
point in time later on
but the they don't have the same they
are not like this right they don't
uh you have you have some transition
probability
which may also suggest the possibility
of losses
uh you have
inconsistency here
but moreover
on top of that you have the situation
that row one is less than row zero and
if you'd like to have it the other way
around you can reverse time you it's
it's easy to
to uh stay you can have a time symmetric
formulation
so the question in the spirit of
strodger is this
again what is the most likely evolution
that accounts for losses so when you
have losses
you you need some prior
law that accounts for losses and then
you need to adapt that so
the the natural thing to have is you
have again a diffusion
with a prior killing rate
so according to some
prior
uh
mechanism particles disappear
so
uh this is called killing rate in
relation to feynman catch and we're
going to see the connection
or some sort of uh juxtaposition of the
two
so in this context because we're really
looking at the evolution of particles
and not uh
not um um
[Music]
taking statistics of any sort
uh we
we postulate that the state space
is the space where the particles diffuse
uh
union a coffin state
when they die the trajectories disappear
and then
they can be seen to
us being transitioned into that
so then the path here is
is the um the score hold space
or for
of from
functions from zero to one to x
so there's a continuous path and then
you have a jump
to the coffin state
um
and uh
so every path we can view it as as some
of them discontinued halfway in jumping
to the
the uh the coughing
state according to this uh
this this law so
now
rows are the original densities
and peas from this point on
are
natural augmentations
where you add mass
in the coffin state to account for how
many were lost
so you start from row zero and zero and
then you have row one and one minus the
integral
and then the problem becomes becomes
this
so it's very similar
uh
the original
um
schrodinger formulation
so
um
the focus planck equation for diffusion
with killing
is again the focus plank except that you
have a term over here that accounts for
losses
these are one-time margins again and you
you have this
scaling with v that gives you the losses
so
um
now
the
the there's going to be again
fives and phi hats which are
kind of we can you can view them as
lagrange multipliers
trying to solve the optimization problem
before but now you have an additional
one one which depends on
time and space and one which depends on
time
because the state space is has expanded
and uh then
this leads to a new schrodinger system
where again you have the
the the forward evolution for phi hat
now again the five hat is going to have
two components
one for the continuous part of the space
and one for the discrete and the
discrete
accumulates the amount of mass that is
lost
and then here you have this uh the dual
which turns out to be this
and the matching conditions
and then again virtually everything
works with modules on technicalities
verbatim
at least it looks like
so
um
let me see what is the time
one minute oh oh one minute okay
so so that
there is i'm i'm finishing very quickly
so there's a dynamic formulation of this
where again you have uh
uh
you have now an updated thing in a big
term for the losses
so the not only you update the the drift
here but your play update the losses
and the master accumulates at uh the
coffin state is given by this
there are these added terms and you can
also relate this to a fluid dynamic
formulation so you can uh
replace the previous problem with one
which you have over here
the here you have a focal plank with
losses and here you have another term
that penalizes how much
uh you're losing
and then i just wanted to mention one
thing that there have been some attempts
to
link such a problem to find mankatc
and
um so going back to nagasava or called
leonard and ourselves as well we played
with this where the defendant catch uh
so rationale is you re-weight uh a
measure
with uh something that accounts for the
losses but this
does not really address the problem
where particles are lost
because the
this
represents uh the probability for
surviving particles it's again
uh a probability density you don't you
don't have
the structure that we thought that the
mass reduces
so the downside is that is this the
upside is that the schrodinger problem
is easier i have not written it down the
downside is non-physical and
inconsistent with short guessed dictum
and these are the reasons
for example if the row one is consistent
with the prior model and the losses
if you solve this problem you don't get
the the prior
like if i give you a prior and i give
you the margin it's all consistent
you're supposed to recover it if it's
consistent
if you formulate like that you don't
you have to formulate it like before
with the
the um
uh the coughing state and here are some
simulations where you have
simple diffusion and killing rate
and um
uh depending on
on the mass at the very end so here the
mass at the beginning at the end are the
same
so you you see how the the schrodinger
transports the mass across
if the end mass is less
you get this this expression
now if you use um
the re-weighted process uh using the
feynman catch
you have no way of adjusting the v
and this shows the the rate of uh
survived mass
and with us this this is the archive
version of the paper and without this i
would like to
thank you for your attention
[Applause]
is
and then the mass disappears but um
i also think that you know you really
have two states you know as you said
discrete and you're just transferring
the mass from you know one coffee
i don't see why not
you can have multiple yes yeah i mean i
i think that uh again this is just the
the very basic problem
uh
there are other layers you can think of
you know
vector valued for example distributions
and then
different things disappear at different
rates and different
um
different ways and and you postulate
whatever the physics tells you
and then you try to adjust it or you
postulate whatever you
you know from from your desired uh sort
of
answer to some some practical problem
images or whatever
and then you try to smooth it out in a
way that makes it consistent
hi so this might be a very silly
question but
most of the times we model progressive
processes as you know as measures over
time at times the on the underlying
wiener space right
so can we look at the evolution of this
measure
in time in the sense that disappearing
particles are actually stuck in time
sort of like that
you
know yeah so because
if you consider zero to one you get a
the product is also like a probability
measure on this yes so is there a
reformulation where you consider this
evolution and the particles just get
stuck there according to some rate it
may be a poisson tick or something
i mean this is
kind of that okay
but um
you know that's
stuck in time you can think of it as i i
don't know maybe
young thing you might want it's not
basically the way you add
here we just add one coffin state to
account for the loss of mass if you want
to model the
some particle get stuck in time you just
say
just say build your coffin state the
coffin state is really id so you get
stuck there you just keep there you
don't move anymore you just say just
twice as complex as the original problem
but it's doable
yeah
yeah
yeah in various ways i mean again you
can
this is just a model of
one last question
very beautiful talk thank you
so
i had a couple of questions so one was
so whether
d
can be also negative or uh is uh assumed
to be positive and he stays positive
so um so
for for this
we're thinking of be positive
being negative we represent creation
and we we're currently working on
something along this direction where you
have both creation and
killing
but it's a little bit more subtle
okay so
in the sense that uh there is a
a little bit of a trade-off that uh
now it's very difficult to explain but
uh how much
if there's a pool
that will allow you to to generate
particles coming in so it's there's no
simple answer
quick answer yeah instead of you know
that rate is like that and birth rate uh
together
yeah in principle there's no reason why
not but the details are not all uh
worked out i don't know young you
yeah it's
it's slightly more tricky than this i
mean the
problem
you see when you can see the the reason
we consider the
uh the killing only is because
if the process is killing
right you you probably use you know the
total number of particles is uh really
at the beginning after you know the
number of particles is fixed there it
just somebody will get killed
so
and but if you have kidneys you don't
have a good estimation of the total
number of particles but if you want to
use the large deviation theory basically
if the large deviation tells you
probability nothing to happen is
is proportional to either the power
minus n and multiply the rate function
and this end is very important if this
number of particle is also changing it
becomes a
uh
much more tricky and we we don't have a
really good
uh rigorous way of dealing with this
but i mean computationally you can do
this is no problem but just
interpretation
to justify this
[Music]
okay i suggest sir we stop here you can
talk to